[موسيقى]
الشمس القمر الثريا هي مرتكزات الحسابي
عند العرب فهذه الثلاثه اثاث تنفرد وتجتمع
بشكل ثنائي فاجتماع الشمس بالقمر يحدث
كسوف الشمس وهي مرحله ولاده الهلال وفيها
ينتقل القمر من جهه الشمس الغربيه التابعه
لشهر المنصرم الى جهتها الشرقيه التابعه
لشهر الجديد واجتماع الشمس بثريا تسمى
الكنه وهي مرحله اختفاء الثريا عن الانظار
لدخولها في حمره شعاع الشمس واجتماع القمر
بالثريا تسمى بالاقتران والاقتران احد
محطات القمر الشهريه والعربه القدماء
يسمونها بالمنازل عرفت منازلا بشعاب شرج
فحييت المنازل والشعابه منازل هيدت للقلب
شوقا وللعينين دمعا
واكتئابك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والعرب عندهم سته اقترانات هامه وعن
طريقها يعرفون بدايه وشده ونهايه الحر
والبرد والربيع فوقع القمر بجانب ثريا في
اليوم الاول من الشهر الهجري اماره وعلامه
على بدايه البوادر الصيفيه النهاريه
والعامه يقولون جراند حادي على الماء
ترادي
[موسيقى]